my name is Greg and I'm John we're gonna
watch the trailer today for the greasy
strangler that's right
oh yeah fun upbeat YouTube channel crazy
there's a crazy trailer yeah I've heard
this is a very divisive move I've heard
this is a very yes segregation is the
word I believe that's being used around
those parts No all kinds of people can
be disgusted sorry I'm expanding my
vocabulary allow me please I'm learning
new words how what they mean but you
know what words or sentences scenes of
excessive greasiness I like is pink band
I'm calling because I think it just
might be possible my dad Ronnie is the
greasy strangler you probably think I'm
the greasy strangler
two secret whoa that was I mean the fact
that it played in a bunch of places that
makes me want to go watch it just
because I'm like this must be I like
that [ __ ] crazy and I like it [ __ ] crazy
when it's done well I don't like it when
it's like just there trying to be
batshit crazy something about this looks
there's like a dark I want to say
authenticity it looks great on you in in
the way like something like a John
Waters thing looks crazy like yes it
looks like it's really vulgar in a way
but it also looks compellingly odd so
it's about a father and son interesting
I guess okay yeah I'm gonna look at the
plot right here's what in dubis says
Ronny runs a disco walking tour with his
son Braden when a sexy woman takes the
tour it begins a competition between
father and son
for her love it also signals the arrival
of an oily strangler who stalks the
streets at night why that sounds awesome
there's like a fresh film yeah Lee I
mean you don't see stuff like this ever
people don't invest in stuff like this
anymore I'd be very curious to check
this out I like spectravision a lot I
like what they what they do and I'm glad
they're keeping weird and stuff like
this alive I like the first just opening
scene between them between the father
and the son like the dynamics looks like
it'd be a blast to watch yeah like these
new like oddly deadpan yeah I was
reading about this today just like it
seems like it is a weird movie about
weird people yeah it looks great in that
way
looking at these images it looks like
it's out of a different era yeah
the greasy strangler looks this bit like
punches subdued in the face and his face
goes yeah see you like it eyeball
popping out we're gonna help ya it's
like totally wagging it leaves like a
circular hole oh my god it just looks so
cartoony yeah it looks like zany and
wild yeah that's inventive I like a a
low-budget inventive flick a psychedelic
trip like super fun art trash but on
shrooms oh you would die maybe you know
I have a really good time I'd have a
great time when I go on shrooms I prefer
to think of dark stuff a lot of people
are like you gotta make sure you're in a
good mentality before he takes rooms not
this guy I believe all about channeling
the darkness because when you can
conquer the darkness that's they become
Batman people if you're new to the
channel subscribe today
it might be worth my time and John has
reasons to GRE video season on that
playlist most importantly if you've come
to this video because you're a horror
fan hey blue mouse calm he's a social
media manager of it go check it out if
you're a fan of horror like us to you
horror or weird stuff of any kind oops
let me let me do the can't cut the
camera no uh this dog falls on her
Facebook Instagram Twitter it's almost
perfect he's almost won a whole video I
don't know